connaissez-vous l'anacardier c'est cet
arbre qui produit la noix de cajou elle
pose surtout en Afrique de l'Ouest et au
Brésil mais cette noix est
principalement décortiquée en Inde et au
Vietnam
en 2020 il s'est produit plus de 4
millions de tonnes de noix de cajou dans
le monde et la demande est toujours
croissante ça reste une collation qui
est facile qui se conserve très bien
ça fait que la consommation agisse
exploser
la montée du végétalisme n'y est pour
quelque chose la noix de cajou est
pratique et polyvalente et c'est une
protéine contenant de bons gras on peut
faire un lait végétal qu'on peut en
faire des yogourts des fromages on peut
les cuisiner de toutes sortes de façon
cette popularité a fait grimper le prix
de cette noix vendu maintenant autour de
30 dollars le kilo comparativement à 10
dollars pour l'arachide et 25 dollars
pour la Mende pourquoi c'est si cher
déjà lorsqu'on plante l'arbre je pense
qu'il faut attendre 5 à 7 années pour
que la puisse donner des fruits
raconte nous travaille chez pr
international un des plus gros
importateurs de noix de cajou au Canada
il faut payer un transport de l'Afrique
du SCO Vietnam ou en Inde ensuite il
faut tout un processus de transformation
et puis c'est une production qui prend
énormément de main d'oeuvre si je prends
l'exemple d'une usine qui transforme
environ 15000 tonnes de noix de cajou
annuellement il faut jusqu'à environ 400
personnes pour travailler dans cette
usine là
[Musique]
c'est la deuxième coque à l'intérieur de
la noix qui nécessite autant de main
d'oeuvre elle doit être enlevée
manuellement à l'aide d'un couteau il
faut environ 4 conteneurs et plus de
noix de cajou brut pour fabriquer un
conteneur de noix de cajou
au fil des ans le Vietnam est devenu le
premier exportateur mondial il a expédié
4 milliards de dollars de noix de cajou
en 2021 différentes tailles sont
importées c'est ce qu'on appelle les
grades c'est ce qui établit aussi le
prix de la noix
320 c'est comme la taille moyenne des
noix de cajou c'est ce qu'on retrouve le
plus
320s ça veut dire que c'est à peu près
320 morceaux de cajou qu'on peut trouver
comme dans 454 g
mais c'est grade ne figure pas sur les
emballages des produits d'épicerie le
consommateur a d'ailleurs peu
d'informations pour choisir ses noix de
cajou
je vous ai apporté des produits qu'on a
acheté en épicerie le qu'on trouve à peu
près partout on dit que c'est fabriqué
au Canada à partir d'ingrédients
canadiens et importés on sait pas
nécessairement d'ouvrir la noix de cajou
c'est sûr que le Canada ne produit pas
de noix de cajou ici on dit que c'est un
produit des États-Unis c'est
certainement le remplissage et
l'emballage qui a été fait aux
États-Unis
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça premium
normalement c'est pour faire référence à
la qualité ce qui veut dire c'est une
qualité première mais en même temps ici
c'est peut-être juste un thème pour
attirer le consommateur alors ici dans
l'entrepôt c'est
que des oui et nous avons des noix nous
avons des fruits secs aussi est-ce
qu'elles viennent toutes du Vietnam et
si vous avez des noix de cajou du Brésil
et la particularité ici c'est des cassos
qui sont biologiques il a si biologique
mais c'est pas nécessairement équitable
parce que pour soi équitable il faut que
d'autres critères soient prises en
compte donc ce qui n'est pas forcément
le cas
[Musique]
sur l'avenue Mont-Royal à Montréal
Christian guillolo vient livrer ses noix
de cajou à la boutique vrac et bocaux
c'est pas tous les fournisseurs qui nous
offrent des produits équitables rares
sont ceux qui le font la noix dans sa
forme originale Christian Guillot et le
seul au Canada à offrir des noix de
cajouisables pourquoi il y en a si peu
il y en a si peu probablement parce que
comme souvent dans les produits
équitables on va payer un peu plus cher
parce que évidemment il y a des
conditions de salaire de rémunération
des producteurs qui sont supérieurs bien
sûr c'est un produit aussi biologique
même si on recense des centaines de
petits producteurs de noix de cajouis
équitables cette production reste
marginale et l'importance d'avoir un
commerce équitable pour la noix de cajou
c'est quoi selon vous beaucoup de
consommateurs ont été alertés lors d'un
reportage qui était tourné en Inde où on
voit dans des ateliers que les femmes
essentiellement des femmes décortiquent
les noix à la main sans aucune
protection et il faut savoir que à
l'intérieur des coques des noix on
trouve une substance une sorte d'acide
qui est extrêmement allergène et qui
peut même brûler les mains sur les
manipules à longueur de journée est-ce
que c'est la majorité des cas je n'en
sais rien je dirige en doute maintenant
voilà c'est au commerçants aux
importateurs de le démontrer de le
prouver je dirais que ça s'est beaucoup
amélioré au cours de ces dernières
années j'ai eu l'opportunité d'aller
visiter l'usine d'un de nos fournisseurs
au Nigeria les gens étaient bien équipés
pour travailler vous avez pas
d'assurance que partout dans le monde
c'est bien respecté comme ça non il faut
dire on fait pas le taux de toutes les
usines souvent les produits équitables
coûtent beaucoup plus cher mais humano
réussi à offrir un produit à prix de
compétitif dans la moyenne de
l'industrie à peu près 30% de noix qui
vont se trouver briser on les
commercialise quand même parce qu'en
plus elles sont aussi bonnes
les jeunes consommateurs se préoccupent
beaucoup de l'environnement et des
conditions des travailleurs ce qui fait
bondir la vente des noix bio et
équitables c'est vrai que il y a une
tendance beaucoup de plus en plus forte
je vais la noix de cajou biologique mais
c'est la noix de cajou conventionnelle
qui domine encore le marché jusqu'au
jour aujourd'hui
[Musique]